films were once seen as superior to
television in Hollywood but with the
rise of streaming platforms and cable
television is enjoying a surge in
popularity and prestige like never
before now even a list talent is
flocking to television to tackle meaty
roles once reserved for the big screen
as the new golden age of television
stretches on here are a few TV roles
everyone in Hollywood wanted to play
Carrie Bradshaw
Sex in the City it was Sarah Jessica
Parker's career defining role but other
actresses nearly done sex columnist
Carrie Bradshaw's little tutu on the hit
HBO comedy Sex in the City
series creator Darren star initially
asked China Beach and Desperate
Housewives star Dana Delany to play
Carrie after seeing her on stage with
Kim Cattrall Delaney declined not
wanting to be in a show about sex
although she encouraged Cottrell to
accept the role of Samantha Parker was
next on stars list but she was unsure so
he offered the role to Linda Edelstein
best recalled today for her role on a
house as a backup Edelstein signed a
contract but Parker finally said yes
leaving star to let Edelstein go ouch as
Carrie Bradshaw knows breaking up is
hard to do why is it so hard for you to
factor me into your life in any real way
Don Draper Mad Men Don Draper's Sterling
Cooper's best ad man capable of selling
anything from the Kodak carousel to
coca-cola with equal parts showmanship
and charm in future Emmy winner Jon Hamm
needed to do some serious selling to
convince AMC and series creator Matthew
whiner he was the right man to fill
Draper's immaculately tailored 1960
suits in Mad Men a virtual unknown at
the time with a string of tiny film and
TV credits ham was basically at the
bottom of everyone's list ham revealed a
podcast host Mark Marin that Mad Men's
casting directors originally went to
punisher star Thomas Jane who promptly
turned down their offer saying he didn't
do television
Roger Sterling himself actor John
Slattery initially auditioned to play
done but whiner only wanted him for the
wisecracking silver fox sterling they
wanted me read for his part which who
wouldn't you know and I thought I did a
really good job actually with both Jane
and Slattery out of the running
Winer asked execs to look at two
finalists ham and youngers Peter Herman
AMC flu ham to New York where he charmed
programming execs over drinks at the
gains of
or hotel and won the role on the spot
doing business during cocktails the
under a permit surely approve sama Diane
Cheers
for the first half of Cheers 11 season
run the show's comedy was propelled by
the sexual tension between egotistical
womanizing bar owner Sam Malone and
Brainiac feminist waitress Diane
chambers there will they won't they
love-hate relationship became must-see
TV and catapulted Ted Danson and Shelley
Long to emmy-winning fame coming off the
success of taxi sidling writers GLAAD
and les Charles and director James
burrows wanted to create another
workplace comedy but said in a bar and
they knew Sam and Diane would be the key
to making it work they saw hundreds of
actors before narrowing it down to three
pairs that were brought in for a final
audition Ted Danson and Shelley Long
former football player Fred dryer and
new hearts Julia Duffy and Nats landings
William Devane and Lisa Eichhorn while
the team really like Dreyer and Duffy
the chemistry between Danson and long
was instant and undeniable
Michael Scott the office steve carell
became a star thanks to his brilliant
cringe-worthy and occasionally
heartbreaking turn as Dunder Mifflin's
bumbling boss Michael Scott
sheíll runner Craig Daniels audition
actors a little differently for the show
conducting interviews and having them
improv answers as their characters that
probably made it pretty hard auditions
for the show were a veritable who's who
of comedy actors Rainn Wilson was the
first person to audition for Michael but
Daniels felt he was far better suited
for power-hungry Dwight Schrute Hank
Azaria from The Simpsons better call
Saul's Bob Odenkirk and Alan Tudyk all
auditioned for Michael as well an NBC
chief Kevin Reilly offered the role to
Oscar nominee Paul Giamatti but he
turned it down
Universal Pictures chairwoman Stacey
Snider encouraged the network to hire
the ex Daily Show correspondent Carell
and the rest was sitcom history negan
the walking dead The Walking Dead fans
spent months eagerly anticipating the
introduction of negan the show's most
sadistic and arguably most compelling
villain of course first the producers
had to find just the right person to
play him punk rock icon and actor Henry
Rollins told Forbes he was the
inspiration for the characters look in
the original comic books inspiring
Walking Dead artist Charlie Adlard
Rollins tried out for the role for which
he thought he was a shoo-in but he
didn't get it creator Robert Kirkman
told MTV he thought Jon Hamm of Mad Men
would be perfect for negan and Hamm
expressed interest garret dillahunt the
versatile character actor best known for
playing the goofy grandpa and raising
hope and two separate characters on
Deadwood lobby publicly on Twitter for
the role evidently none of them could
swing it as well as the guy who got the
part Jeffrey Dean Morgan Olivia Pope
scandal when word got out that Grey's
Anatomy creator Shonda Rhimes was
working on a new show lots of actresses
were interested like Grey's Anatomy that
new series titled scandal offered prime
roles for women notably that of the lead
character Washington DC fixer Olivia
Pope Rhimes told The Hollywood Reporter
that early on one ABC exec argued Pope
would be perfect for Connie Britton to
which she replied it would be except
Olivia Pope is black Rhimes had based
the character on real-life DC problem
solver Judy Smith who is
african-american and she wanted to honor
her identity and heritage Gabrielle
Union was a
contender until Access Hollywood live
that she and half of black Hollywood
were interested in the role adding that
she made it into the final round of five
or six actresses
taraji P Henson who'd go on to play
cookie Lyon on Empire audition but knew
she wouldn't get it
audition for Shonda Rhimes for scandal I
didn't thank God Carrie that indeed
actress Kerry Washington got the gig and
she's perfect for it thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you